[Musique]
bienvenue au village itinérant agricole
de l'europe
animé par le crij centre régional
information jeunesse et le département
ce village présente au travers d'un
parcours découverte et différentes
facettes du monde agricole et les aides
européennes feader à la réunion
aujourd'hui le département a voulu
sensibiliser les collégiens au potentiel
que peut leur offrir le monde agricole
et comprendre comment l'europe
au travers du feader
que ce soit au développement des
filières le développement des os et
jusqu'aux grands projets d'irrigation du
littoral ouest six collèges sont invités
pour cette journée de sensibilisation
les jeunes avec ses ateliers
participatifs appréhende au plus près
les formations et les métiers dans le
domaine agricole à la réunion on a la
télé témoignages avec la présence donc
d'un témoin dans d'un vrai un vrai
exemple de quelqu'un qui a pu faire le
métier ou des études un lien avec la
culture
nous avons ensuite un atelier formation
donc justement pour expliquer les
formations qui existe à la réunion dans
le domaine un atelier métier pour
introduire les différents métiers
existants dans le domaine et pour finir
un atelier qu'on appelle europe pour
présenter un peu ce que c'est l'europe
présent une journée sur la commune de
bras-panon et une autre à la possession
le village agricole européen va au plus
près des jeunes réunionnais pour
susciter de nouvelles vocations dans un
secteur en plein développement
[Musique]